Hello
Hello Bhai Jaan Thank you Choudhary and your
watching date is that Sun welcome to the series
of funds in the middle of Machine Learning
Artificial Intelligence this point to so in this
video Bihar Learning about various
types of Machine Learning how many such machines are
there and here  But we are going to talk about their
last three types,
subscribe if
you liked it, like
this video, let's do it
first by
subscribing to ours, so that
you have
happened and such a letter that we are telling him
that  It should have a designer and code, so you
can understand something like this, the supervisor said,
what do we do here, we
implement the data, send us your example, let's
see and I can take you to a screen,
if we see it directly.  First of all,
if we have a person like Ana wearing a t-shirt, to
do something specific, there
are various types of off in it and we
classify it that if there is ever a call, it
is a village caller and inside it also there are corpses, medium
access etc., so now we are classifying.  We are
telling the machine that this is a machine, if such a
t-shirt comes, then this is the last stage, medium size, then
click on this is not provided,
then
here we were subscribed, on the
festival side, we become tasty,
whatever accuracy you are getting, that machine gives it.
Is not able to understand and we do
not need to input the data. If such turning around
comes on five sense and cent percent then
we can accept it on a good regulator
and there will be Bihar reading option for voting machine.
Test means that kidney Amazing.  We are
setting
this lone ad supervisor learning from a model which is on the music train,
so if we look at where our supervisor is
appointed, where is our eating habit
best for skin problems, then within this comes the
classification problem, so there is a classification
problem in which you  Gave an example of
how we can differentiate ourselves from a model like a
t-shirt or anything like a laptop, it is
okay in this method, any cutting is special,
we will make a laptop by attending the class, add to it that
you can go on vacation and the problem ends.  Country comes to
liberation problem, if we
look at the relation problem then here
what is the reaction problem and bloody mary
worth life, there will be no change with this,
so the extract is coming, this change
happened in 2014,
appointed in 2015, so you
can see.
Combine folds in it
and on top of that,
let's talk about
unsupervised learning from downstream, then you
can understand that it is a girl who is without supervision
but how are they, then
at the end of Anand, why was the model called machine
learning if  We have one and a half halls and a lot of
details and so many data centers that if we
start leveling them one by one, it will not take a lot of
time and a lot of cords can go
into this thing, so to reduce this thing,
we have taken unsupervised learning.
What does Sopan Supervisor do? We
use the previous defeating models, so we
train them with the data, with some examples like some images, it
seems like flowers
that NDA recipe is being trained directly by doing everything in it,
he is interested in the
date of  When we put in it, only that
thing is on the real output, it is different things,
different price, champion, Spain, quite, it
fits well with the images, this is not the battery and
this is the one with which it is matching, it is not
happening, something like this.  Now let us talk
a little more in unsupervised learning, so
if
you see the pattern school by using your
details which have penetrated deep learning
models, then we will talk in the Gurjar dance poisoning give all
videos.
So, if we see then  On that I
apply CCR i.e. Neural Networks, it
notices some patterns there, if it does
light decoration flower classification in this image,
then takes
sampling pattern of flowers, it will do this amazing thing
Bigg Boss, now from the image, by
doing like this  He makes different last fights,
puts different flowers in different decrees and we will see
how else, when he returns last, then on one
side of them, good example of 9 to
separate them without that news of Sunday Times
Dandruff
Image Hi De Diya Vanvas Jaati She Fool
Images Full Images Of People From
See this where is the application now,
so we can see that if we are
in a bank in a pack, if you have used it for clothes and
depression, you can use us for a
for  How can one use detection in this?
Here, instead of debit card classes, it is
two places and equal, in California,
India, we have tried separately in Bangalore and Delhi,
how can one swipe in war, that
mixture is special two.  That
bank can also do meat and production
and this clustering can also be used to bridge different data if there is a lot of data.
Bihar SSC that we should take some solution, we
are buying some things online,
Flipkart, Amazon gives better price.
Start talking like stop from side Choos you are talking
anything close run away then same
crush will be taken this solution now extra it
like this
suggestions of different different types of objective voice he
unsupervised learning difficulties of funds
for boys in quality and its  If you
look inside, how can accuracy be achieved? It is
very tasty. Till date, research has also said
that as much as one stitch can go in this romantic beat, it is
not possible to salivate. That's why
we come. Supervisor
also uses it, but it is quite  The cost is this, I
increase it a bit, I do the supervisor while using the fast medium and
not, I
try to suppress more regulation, we try to
get the best accuracy inside it and can use 19 models,
so in this video you saw that the supervisor  What is
turning and unsupervised learning, who goes
the most,
how much time is spent, supervision costs more, it
costs less because of the words, planning
models, username: unsupervised learning,
guys, after this we
will see reinforcement learning.  If you like the content in the next video,
please like
and share so that the device
is appreciated
[Music]